in the past we obviously had a lot less
people right we only had half a billion
people for the entirety of the history
of the world till the Industrial
Revolution and then with the Green
Revolution and nitrogen fertilizer and
oil and like that we went from half a
billion people to 8 billion people
overnight in historical
timelines and we went from those people
mostly living on local subsistance to
almost all living on dependent upon very
complicated Supply chains now that are
six continent mediated Supply chains so
that means that uh there's radically
more fragility in the life support
systems so that local catastrophes can
turn to breakdowns of Supply chains
economic effects Etc that affect people
very wiely